Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field, the principles can work for you.
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件正在进行的激动人心的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，这些原则都同样适用。
There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode.
挑战中还有由Lisa本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢得与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导时间。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。
If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to this episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Today we're going to be thinking about using supervision and the supervisory relationship. Now of course as an aspiring psychologist it's really important that we have got some sort of supervision which helps us feel contained, that helps us also ideally in a a really ideal world, advance our skills across, you know, a pretty broad skill set. So I have to say that I've always been reasonably fortunate with my psychology supervision, and that I've been able to use it and shape it to get, you know know to get the best out of me and to serve my clients and the service as well as I can and also you know to I get basically I always used to think of as an assistant psychologist
如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南。我是Marianne Trent博士。你好，欢迎收听本期《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是Marianne Trent博士。今天我们要探讨的是如何利用督导以及督导关系。当然，作为一名有抱负的心理学家，拥有某种形式的督导非常重要，它能帮助我们感到被接纳，并在理想情况下，帮助我们提升广泛的技能。我必须说，我在心理学督导方面一直比较幸运，我能够利用并塑造它，从而发挥出我的最佳水平，尽可能好地服务于我的客户和机构。而且，我基本上一直认为，作为一名助理心理学家，
as a way of helping you know the qualified psychology team do their job optimally so in very much the way that I run my private business now if the job doesn't actually need to be done by me it can be done with someone with skills in a certain area then actually there's a school of thought that says I ought not to be doing it because it's not the best value for money so I don't have I don't have any assistant psychologists on my payroll currently other than writing blog posts which I will pay you 15 pounds to write for me if that's interesting to you do give me a shout but you know I recognize that I'm a good writer you know I enjoy writing I always have um but um you know it doesn't really make sense for me to write that stuff myself when actually I can use you know that hour of my time um in a much more, you know, lucrative way for me and in an effective way, hopefully, for my clients. So yeah, if you're interested in that, do give me a shout. But anyway, I digress.
这是一种帮助合格的心理学团队优化工作的方式。就像我现在经营私人业务一样，如果这项工作不需要我亲自完成，而可以由具备特定技能的人来完成，那么有一种观点认为我不应该去做，因为那不是性价比最高的。所以我目前没有雇佣任何助理心理学家，除了撰写博客文章——如果你对此感兴趣，写一篇我可以付你15英镑，请告诉我。但我知道我擅长写作，我也一直很享受写作，但如果我能把那一小时的时间用在对我来说更有利可图、对客户更有效的方式上，我自己去写这些东西确实没有意义。所以，如果你感兴趣，请告诉我。总之，我跑题了。
So using supervision is a way for helping to make sure that I was supporting and that you would be supporting, you know, the needs of that qualified psychology team to help them do their job more optimally. So I know when I was an assistant psychologist, it meant that I was doing kind of some of the audit stuff and maybe helping to, you know, pre-score up some of the psychology measures and questionnaires. I had a job in a forensic setting where there was quite a lot of challenging and sexually inappropriate behavior and so I would log all of that and keep it in a database. I made a wicked Excel spreadsheet, I love a bit of excel and you know used that to be able to generate trends and then to be able to write reports for people's CPA reviews so that was you know I learned so much
因此，利用督导是确保我能够支持，并且你也能支持合格心理学团队需求的一种方式，帮助他们更优化地工作。我知道当我还是助理心理学家时，这意味着我需要做一些审计工作，或许还要帮助预先评分一些心理测量和问卷。我曾在法医环境中工作，那里有很多具有挑战性和性不当的行为，我会记录所有这些并保存在数据库中。我制作了一个很棒的Excel表格，我喜欢Excel，并利用它来生成趋势，然后为人们的CPA审查撰写报告，所以我学到了很多。
there I'm going to ward rounds either with the psychologist or as a psychologist kind of deputy to go and feedback anything or to, you know, to try and contribute as much as I could with my burgeoning psychology experience. But me and meetings are still not great. You know, long meetings. Oh, I find that a bit of a struggle. So, yeah, if you're in that same camp, welcome to my world. Anyway, so using supervision effectively, it's it's kind of important that you feel safe and a way that you can help think about developing the best possible relationship is to think about contracting and that's something that I've always done in my own supervision but also when I'm supervising other members of staff, too. And you might be like, I don't really know what a supervision contract is.
在那里，我要么和心理学家一起参加查房，要么作为心理学家的副手去反馈信息，或者尽我所能贡献我日益增长的心理学经验。但会议对我来说仍然不是强项。你知道，冗长的会议，我觉得有点吃力。所以，如果你也一样，欢迎来到我的世界。总之，有效地利用督导，重要的是你要感到安全。建立最佳关系的一种方法是考虑签订契约，这是我在自己的督导中一直做的，也是我在督导其他员工时所做的。你可能会问，我不太清楚什么是督导契约。
And if you'd like to download my example of a supervision contract that you might want to use to shape your thinking and to shape your conversations with, you know, either current supervisors or new supervisors then do go to www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash supervision so www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash supervision and what I will do is you will automatically then be sent my supervision contract and I hope you find that really useful because it has been superbly useful for me you know across my career so I hope you find the same too but it gives you the opportunity to to take away that ambiguity to really know you know what happens if our relationship gets a bit tricky so it's got conversations to support that as well you know it helped me understand what the expectations are of me during supervision um and just to check in know, with the fact that I know what I'm being
如果你想下载我提供的督导契约范例，用来塑造你的思维并指导你与现任或新任督导的对话，请访问 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/supervision。访问后，你将自动收到我的督导契约。我希望你觉得它非常有用，因为它在我的职业生涯中一直非常有用。它让你有机会消除模糊性，真正了解如果我们的关系变得棘手时会发生什么，它也包含支持这些对话的内容。它帮助我理解在督导期间对我的期望，并确认我清楚自己被要求做什么，以及我对督导中的其他人有什么期望。
asked to do and what I'm expecting of others in supervision. It can also be useful to think about, you know, how protected your supervisor's time is. So I think for me me it's important to think about developing your distress tolerance but it also takes time to work out what is appropriate you know distress tolerance and containment so containment um in case you're not sure is kind of the ability to keep stuff together without it leaking out every now and then so I know I was probably quite annoying in my first assistant post because anything that cropped up to me I'd be like emailing it and asking it as a question but over time I have got better and more contained at holding that unless it's issues of imminent risk to myself or the service user or the staff team. Because, of course, we ought not to be keeping that to the next available supervision.
思考督导的时间保护程度也很有用。我认为对我来说，培养压力承受能力很重要，但弄清楚什么是适当的压力承受和接纳也需要时间。接纳，如果你不确定的话，就是一种保持状态而不让情绪偶尔泄露的能力。我知道我在第一份助理工作中可能很烦人，因为任何出现的问题我都会发邮件询问。但随着时间的推移，我变得更好、更克制了，除非是涉及我自己、服务对象或员工团队的迫在眉睫的风险。因为当然，我们不应该把这些问题留到下一次督导时再说。
And if you're like, well, why not? It's because, of course, we have a duty of care to protect and so if you are concerned about someone's well-being safety then we need to pass that on and that might involve making safeguarding referrals or contacting emergency services whatever needs to happen but again this is a useful conversation to have with your supervisor if you haven haven't had it already, you know, what do I do if something is so big that I can't keep it, you know, for the next supervision? What are the policies and know that you know you might be really busy and that you've obviously told me that um you know that your office hours are such and such and because some supervisors are very bounded um and some are obviously of course so busy that they don't really have capacity to be supervising junior members of the team but of course there was a duty of care to offer supervision but supervision for me isn't just about one hour a week you know or one hour a fortnight or whatever
如果你问为什么，那是因为我们有保护他人的注意义务。所以如果你担心某人的福祉安全，我们需要上报，这可能涉及进行保障转介或联系紧急服务，无论需要做什么。但这同样是与你的督导进行的一次有益对话，如果你还没谈过的话。比如，如果事情大到我无法等到下一次督导怎么办？有哪些政策？你知道，对方可能非常忙，而且显然已经告诉你他们的办公时间是多少，因为有些督导的界限非常明确，而有些显然太忙了，没有能力督导团队中的初级成员。但当然，提供督导是一种注意义务，但对我来说，督导不仅仅是一周一小时，或者两周一小时，无论对你来说是什么样子，
it looks like for you um I really enjoy having um being a supervisor and having that ability to help shape someone. And so whenever I have had someone as my supervisee, I've made sure that I have time for them to be able to, you know, not just have supervision, but to be able to come along to things I'm doing, and to help advance their skills, you know, so to observe assessments. And, you know, sometimes when I was working in, you know, family service where there was a screen, sometimes patients didn't mind. If, you know, junior members of staff sat and observed the session through the window, you know, some did, of course. And you might need to pick um who you ask about that but if you are wanting to you know increase your experience and especially if it is a family session you know it can be useful to have an observer to be able to talk that through with afterwards so afterwards. So is that something you could offer? But yeah, I also used to do the very cringy thing of recording myself and the client on audio during sessions and bringing that to supervision
我真的很喜欢担任督导，并拥有帮助塑造他人的能力。所以每当我拥有督导对象时，我都会确保有时间让他们不仅能接受督导，还能参与我正在做的事情，帮助提升他们的技能，比如观察评估。有时我在家庭服务部门工作时，那里有屏风，有时患者并不介意初级员工坐在窗边观察会谈。当然，有些人会介意，你可能需要选择询问的对象。但如果你想增加经验，特别是如果是家庭会谈，有一个观察者并在事后进行讨论是很有用的。所以我以前也做过非常尴尬的事情，就是在会谈中录下自己和客户的音频，并带到督导中，
so that we could listen to bits, which I promise you feels horrid but you get over the sound of your own voice pretty quickly to be able to advance your skills so you know so if your supervisor doesn't have a chance to to observe you or can't sit in a room and obviously it's not always appropriate would a client let you film some bits so that you can go through that with them so but of course I didn't do loads of therapy before I got on to my doctoral course so done a bit and trust me oh when I look back on it now it was cringeworthy and I say a bit more about that in my story in the clinical psychologist collective book so check that out if you haven't already um but yes psychology supervision should feel safe you know safe to be yourself safe to be able to to say I don't really know
这样我们就可以听一些片段。我向你保证，这感觉很糟糕，但你很快就能克服听到自己声音的不适感，从而提升技能。所以，如果你的督导没有机会观察你，或者无法坐在房间里（显然这并不总是合适的），客户是否会让你录下一些片段，以便你可以和他们一起回顾？当然，我在进入博士课程之前并没有做过大量的治疗，只做了一点点。相信我，现在回想起来，那真是太尴尬了。我在《临床心理学家集体》一书中讲述了更多关于这方面的故事，如果你还没看过，请去看看。是的，心理学督导应该让人感到安全，感到可以做自己，感到可以坦诚地说“我真的不知道”，
what the next step is I don't really know if I feel that that confident or that sure about how to get this result or how to do this and And, you know, if you're doing some neuropsych and you actually don't really know, you could do with a refresher on scoring or interpreting, then it's really important that you feel safe enough to be able to raise your hand in supervision and ask for, you know, some more explicit hand-over-hand guidance or examples so from time in that supervision to go through and problem solve and sometimes in supervision I will you know role play stuff that's gone on with me and clients to be able to demonstrate that with someone that I'm supervising. So that might be another way that you could ask for your supervisor to help shape you is to ask
下一步该怎么做，我不确定自己是否有信心或确定如何获得这个结果或如何做这件事。如果你正在做一些神经心理学工作，而你确实不知道，需要复习评分或解释，那么感到足够安全并在督导中举手请求更明确的指导或示例是非常重要的。在督导期间，我会通过角色扮演我与客户之间发生的事情，向我督导的人进行演示。所以这可能是你要求督导帮助塑造你的另一种方式，就是要求
them to do a little bit of role play with you. We're not talking about dressing up here, but just to say, you know, I'm not really sure how I'd explain that to a client. Could you maybe do that with me? How you think you would usually do that or how it would be appropriate for me to do that so that I can just really get my head around how to do that? And, you know, when you've done a supervision contract contract you know that it's okay to ask those kinds of questions so um I know that in the past I have worked with someone who kind of wasn't okay with me using supervision in that way and asking questions like that and that they felt that made me look like I was not really good enough but actually what I've been able to work through is actually that's kind of an erroneous viewpoint for me
他们和你进行一点角色扮演。我们不是在谈论装扮，只是说，我不确定该如何向客户解释这一点。你能和我一起演练一下吗？你通常会怎么做，或者我怎么做才合适，这样我才能真正理解该怎么做。当你签订了督导契约，你就知道提出这类问题是可以的。我知道过去我曾与某人共事，他们不太接受我以这种方式利用督导并提出这类问题，他们觉得这让我看起来不够优秀。但实际上，我能够克服的是，这对我来说是一种错误的观点，
because it's so far outside everything else that I've ever experienced about supervision. Actually, I think this was just the case of us not being that well attuned. And that does crop up in supervision relationships from time to time. I'm just going to take a short break for a little advert and let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look.
因为它与我以往对督导的所有体验都相去甚远。实际上，我认为这只是我们不够契合的情况。这种情况在督导关系中时有发生。我先休息一下，插播一段广告，让这成为你的指南。书中充满了能帮助你获得资格的经验和教训。来看看吧。
It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective Hi, I'm Max and I work as an Assistant Psychologist in the Learning Disability Service in West Yorkshire. Like most people working in psychology, I'm slowly but surely working myself up to that seemingly impossible goal of getting onto the clinical doctorate. With that end goal in mind, I thought I'd have a look at what's out there and see what books might be helpful for this. I came across Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, and decided that this would be a great buy for me to help me on my journey.
就在这本书里。这是《临床心理学家集体》。你好，我是Max，我在西约克郡的学习障碍服务部门担任助理心理学家。像大多数从事心理学工作的人一样，我正在缓慢而坚定地朝着那个看似不可能的目标——进入临床博士课程努力。考虑到这个最终目标，我想看看市面上有什么书能提供帮助。我发现了Marianne的书《临床心理学家集体》，并认为这对我的旅程来说是一次很棒的购买。
I found Marianne's book really informative and most insightful. I especially liked how the stories reassured me that you don't need to be academically perfect to become a psychologist and that as long as you have good interpersonal skills such as compassion and empathy you will get there. I would highly recommend this book to all aspiring psychologists and also those who want to know a bit more about the world of clinical psychology and maybe want to work in that field one day. Thank you. come and take a look it's right here in this book it's the clinical psychologist collective it's the clinical psychologist collective so what happens if um you know if a supervision relationship just isn't really meeting your needs do you feel like it would be okay to ask you know to change that to amend it to try and strengthen and improve your relationship
我发现Marianne的书非常有信息量且富有洞察力。我特别喜欢书中的故事，它们让我确信，成为一名心理学家并不需要学术上完美，只要你具备良好的社交技能，如同情心和共情能力，你就能成功。我强烈向所有有抱负的心理学家，以及那些想了解更多临床心理学世界并希望有一天能在这个领域工作的人推荐这本书。谢谢。来看看吧，就在这本书里，这是《临床心理学家集体》。那么，如果督导关系不能满足你的需求，你会觉得要求改变、修正或加强和改善这种关系是可以的吗？
could you even if things have broken down ask about a new supervisor and it might be that you know there's not anyone in your immediate department where that's possible but if you're in an NHS trust or you know private hospital it might be that there's someone else in a different department who'd be able to be able to support you in that. And it might be that you might need some, some support from HR to help you to improve your relationship. Or if you feel like you're being treated unfairly, that might be something that you wanted to speak about with HR. Really, really tricky, because the power imbalance, which can feel like it's around in this profession, because of course, I recall very well
即使关系破裂，你是否可以询问新的督导？可能你所在的部门没有合适的人选，但如果你在NHS信托机构或私立医院，可能其他部门有人能支持你。你可能需要人力资源部门的支持来帮助改善关系。或者，如果你觉得受到了不公平对待，这可能是你想与人力资源部门谈论的事情。这真的很棘手，因为这个行业中存在的权力失衡，因为我当然记得很清楚，
that, you know, you want someone to be able to think that you're good at the job and that they think that you'd make a good, you know, qualified psychologist and that it's really useful to have their reference and so you know sometimes we can just have that pressure to think that we need to just keep plodding on but you do matter you are important and if if your needs are not being met or you're being treated really unfairly then it's okay to raise that so someone recently had said that their supervisor had said they didn't really have time to write their declensi reference so could they just write it themselves and they just made my heart hurt you know that's not okay you know if you don't have time to do that for someone then you don't have time to be a supervisor um you know someone shouldn't be writing their own reference and it's also how valid that then
你希望别人认为你胜任这份工作，认为你会成为一名优秀的合格心理学家，而且拥有他们的推荐信非常有用。所以有时我们会有压力，觉得我们需要继续忍受。但你很重要，如果你的需求没有得到满足，或者你受到了极不公平的对待，提出这一点是可以的。最近有人说他们的督导表示没有时间写推荐信，所以能不能让他们自己写。这让我感到心痛，这不应该发生。如果你没有时间为别人做这件事，你就没有时间担任督导。一个人不应该自己写推荐信，而且这也会影响其有效性，
is you know if across the country people have written their own reference that's not very that's not very honest you know it's not very probably very fair fair to the prospective clients that you might be working with if you do then get on to a clinical course because you know I can say I'm great but actually what would be better is if my my supervisor was able to demonstrate actually I am all right at what I you know say that I do and you know whether they're able to weave in any kind of you know feedback from clients to help strengthen that example of why I am good at what I do so it's not it's not an easy situation unless you have like a golden supervisor. But, you know, it's important that you're able to feel like it's okay to be yourself
如果全国各地的人都自己写推荐信，那是不诚实的。如果你进入临床课程，这对你未来可能服务的客户也不公平。因为我可以自夸，但如果我的督导能够证明我确实胜任我所说的工作，那会更好。他们是否能够融入客户的反馈来加强我胜任工作的例子，这会更好。所以，除非你有一位黄金督导，否则这不是一个容易的情况。但重要的是，你要感到可以做自己，
and to use that supervision as a safe space. If you have got any questions or feedback or you'd like me to say more about anything, please do get in touch. And of course, do bear in mind that free resource that I mentioned for, you know, the example supervision contract, which you can get hold of a copy by going to www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash supervision. I hope you find this super useful. If you do, please subscribe, like, consider giving it a review, a rating, all of those lovely things. And I will look forward to catching up with you
并把督导当作一个安全的空间。如果你有任何问题、反馈，或者希望我多谈谈某些方面，请务必联系我。当然，别忘了我提到的那个免费资源，即督导契约范例，你可以通过访问 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/supervision 获取副本。我希望你觉得它非常有用。如果觉得有用，请订阅、点赞，并考虑给予评价、评分，所有这些美好的事情。我期待着在
on our next episode soon. Take care. Then let this be your guide With this podcast that you'll say You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence
下一期节目中与你相见。保重。让这成为你的指南，通过这个播客，你会走上获得资格的道路。这是《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书，发现关于不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，成为心理学家没有完美的路径，这让我充满了信心，
that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我不觉得我在做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。